[Music]
you can't miss the work of artists I'm
only in New York this month her solo
show just opened at one of the city's
great museums
she's also the inaugural sculpture for a
massive display space on the city's
popular high line elevated park and
those are just some of the
accomplishments that have earned her
growing recognition as an emerging force
in the art world for ceramicist seem
only attention
has been a long time coming but at age
51 the Chicago born artist is having her
moment these are two pieces you're
working on further Guggenheim New York's
Guggenheim just opened an exhibit of her
work the reward for her winning the
museum's highly prestigious Hugo Boss
prize and the city's Whitney Museum just
bought one of her sculptures for its
collection it's so Saltine what's
happening to me was there a particular
moment when you sense something was
changing maybe is one CBS pretty crazy
it's pretty crazy but Lee's biggest
project yet will open in June how long
have you been working on her about two
years a sculpture for New York's High
Line you call this piece brick house the
title of the Commodores song of course
but Lee says that wasn't her inspiration
I just like the idea of thinking about
femininity in a different way it's
something solid and enduring rather than
always something fragile and weak this
is how tall this is 16 feet and then
it'll sit atop of 5 foot tall plinth her
bass echoes the mud and grass homes of
Cameroon the figures noble face is
framed by cornrows
that cascade down to cowrie shells the
lips and the nose are defined the eyes
are not I never have defined the eyes as
I'm never really representing any
particular person yeah
and so I just stay on this side of
abstraction the piece was cast at
Stratton sculpture studios in
Philadelphia Julia Stratton is co-owned
we use nine thousand pounds of clay to
make it six thousand pounds of bronze to
cast it
she's monumental Lee who never went to
art school was studying philosophy in
college when she took a ceramics class
on a lark I discovered that I was kind
of a kind of had a knack for it she
began to focus on african-american women
in her work and on issues of race and
beauty but the art world told her she
was in the wrong medium how did you
respond to that well I didn't know how
to be a different artist you know it's
not that I had like more guts than
anyone else or that I was stronger I
didn't know how to be someone other than
myself you're stubborn I'm stubborn yeah
I've never felt like I would be embraced
by the art world mm-hmm at large
mainstream success I didn't think was
something that would happen to me why I
you know many years ago dug in my heels
that I was gonna just do exactly what I
wanted to do and I never thought that I
would be understood I didn't think that
a lot of people shared my interest but
the art world has changed
african-american artists like Kerry
James Marshall and Sam Gilliam are now
seeing their work sell for millions at
auction this month one of Lee's
sculptures set a record for the artists
selling for nearly ninety four thousand
dollars do you think that change is
irreversible I do what's happening with
black artists in the art world in the
United States and also globally is more
of a correction than a fad or a fashion
and you know we're unstoppable now I
really feel that way
I really do last month the team at
Stratton studios in Philadelphia put the
finishing touches on brick house and I
think the piece itself is simply
stunning she's a goddess she's an
American goddess
the sculpture was packed up and
carefully hoisted onto a flatbed truck
for the trip to New York
it'll be turned on its side and it'll
just go to the highway you're gonna ride
with it I'm not gonna ride with it what
I'm gonna worry about it and I'll be
there when it arrives and she was late
at night when Brickhouse reached
Manhattan
Simone Lee's sculpture was lifted up
onto an old railroad bridge now part of
the High Line here for the next year and
a half she will loom F eerily above the
Uptown traffic I feel really lucky I
mean I there's there's been a dearth of
sculpture especially that represents
black women and so I'm very honored to
get this opportunity mm-hmm I think it
is something that we need this new spur
of the High Line will open to the public
on June 5th but until then you still can
see work house from the street and she
is absolutely stunning I love what she
said a woman's solid and enduring
instead of fragile and weak I'm gonna
remember that you know I just I can't
believe someone actually told her she
was in the wrong how can you look at her
work and not see me all again and beauty
they also told her her work was too
well-made Wow
well good thing she did that's a new one
for all of us